et on l'a dit aujourd'hui on va dire la
vérité valérie puisque ça fait partie
aussi des médias à prendre ou à laisser
va revenir en quotidienne l'année
prochaine sur ses beats vous le savez
maintenant on l'a dit à tv mag à damien
mercereau
valérie et c'est vrai que ça traînait
depuis longtemps très longtemps c'est
que c'est que de la télé on s'en était
par les mêmes avant à prendre ou à
laisser
valérie on en a parlé tous les deux
exactement va s'arrêter je peux me
permettre simplement à lévis d'embrasser
très très très fort d'avoir les équipes
techniques parce que c'est léo et emilie
même
voilà mon travail et je vous embrasse
tous très fort les garçons et les filles
et on embrasse également la production
j'ai tous mes chroniques et mon urine
d'hommes ont fini mans vraiment un nom
il emilie lopez nussa role in fine sur
bob la banque fait pas tous les citer
mais je vous embrasse très très fort et
merci à tous été spectateur mais 5e
chroniqueur je leur fais une dernière
fois mais le chroniqueur vraiment vous
affichiez vrai qu'on n'a pas pu avoir la
fin qu'on voulait puisqu'il ya eu voilà
on n'a pas d'avenir aurelio les
événements qu'on sait et c'est réussir
le père s'est pas pu dire au revoir à
mes équipes et valérie j'ai eu un petit
creux ne pas pouvoir dire au revoir
dans le cadre de son émission est de 10
renvois roulage équipe hôte et
spectateurs donc merci steve c'est à
dire maintenant qu'elle est on les fera
venir te sont sur la dernière du 18 mai
signal très bien son entendu valérie
puisqu'il fera une spéciale et sachez
qu'on est en train de travailler sur
d'autres choses l'adolescent va bien
décédé on travaille ensemble sera
exactement elle valérie aura sa propre
émission l'année prochaine et ce sera
bien sûr dompter pmp tous les jours à
mes côtés voilà donc c'est vrai qu'elle
sera je pense que vous êtes assez
contente de ce qui se prépare pour voilà
oui vous me connaissez bien donc on
travaille sur des années chose je pense
que vous êtes limite je pense que ça
vous allez faire une belle année je
crois que je vais déjà faire une belle
saison